Hallo herzlich willkommen zu Sallys
Welt. Ich bin ja gerade voll im Putz-
fieber, machen einen Frühjahrsputz.
Ich habe schon fast das ganze Haus
geputzt, außer die Küche und die Bäder, denn Küche und Bäder die sind für mich so
ein eigenständiges Objekt. Es dauert
extrem viel Zeit die Küche auszuräumen,
denn ein Frühjahrsputz bedeutet für mich alle
Schränke von innen auswischen, von außen
auswischen, ausmisten, aufräumen, schön
sortiert wieder zurück räumen. Daher
könnt ihr euch da wirklich auch einen
ganzen Tag dafür Zeit nehmen. Unsere
Küche ist halt nicht so vollgestellt, wie
vielleicht manch andere ich weiß nicht,
aber wir haben halt nicht so eine
Mikrowelle, wo alles drauf steht oder
Gewürze, die draufstehen und offen
herumstehen, deswegen ich zeige euch
jetzt mal;
wir fangen von innen nach außen an. Bei
der Küche ist nämlich ganz wichtig erst
mal die Schränke nicht komplett
ausräumen, sondern Schrank für Schrank
ausräumen, auswischen, das mache ich hier
mit dem Allzweckreiniger, schön sortieren und
dann wieder zurück. Und das machen wir
jetzt hier. Das ist jetzt auch wie so eine Art kleine Room
Tour mit der neuen Küche hier, denn die
hatte ich noch nicht gezeigt. Erstmal
hier wegräumen und dann geht's los.
Wenn ihr eingebrannte Backöfen habt,
wäre das jetzt die perfekte Zeit, um sie
jetzt einzureiben, damit sie einwirken
können.
Ich habe dafür einfach einen Backofen- und
Grillreiniger, der würde jetzt hier
reinkommen. Der hier oben hat Eco-clean,
das heißt die Seitenteile muss ich
sowieso nie sauber machen, der reinigt
sich dann von alleine.
Hier muss ich nur den Boden sauber
machen, aber hier sieht jetzt alles
sauber aus. Das Einzige, was ich gleich
machen werde ist hier noch die
Backbleche ein bisschen mit Backofenreiniger einzureiben und die lege ich
dann hier rein und dann können die
nämlich einwirken, bis ich eben die
übrige Küche geputzt habe. Das machen wir
jetzt doch kurz zusammen.
Bei Backofenreinigern müsst ihr euch
wirklich immer schützen mit Handschuhen
und am besten nehmt ihr eine Bürste und passt
auch immer auf eure übrigen Gegenstände
auf, also nicht an Edelstahl kommen, nicht
ans Edelstahl Waschbecken oder auf Stein-
oberflächen, denn sonst macht ihr euch
die Oberflächen kaputt. Viele würden jetzt
wahrscheinlich sagen: "hey so schmutzig
ist der Backofen doch gar nicht", aber
mein Tipp an euch lasst eure Backofenüberreste nicht einbrennen, denn
ansonsten wird es ja immer schlimmer und
ihr müsst immer mehr putzen und
schrubben. Ich mache das wirklich so, dass
der Backofen immer sauber ist. Einmal die
Woche machen wir dann Backofenreiniger
rein und dann habt ihr auch wirklich nur
ganz wenig Arbeit damit. Ich wirke das jetzt, also ich mach das
jetzt hier kurz
darauf, lass es dann einwirken. Auch
schön die Backbleche, nur wirklich drauf
streichen und dann muss man auch nichts schrubben.
Ich habe jetzt  hier einen recht starken
Backofenreiniger,
da könnt ihr euch wieder diesen Kreis vorstellen, diesen
Reinigungskreis.
Ich habe jetzt hier den Faktor Chemie.
Dann gibt es den Faktor Zeit also das
Einwirkenlassen und den Faktor Mechanik
also das Schrubben.
Wenn ihr jetzt einen sehr starken
Reiniger habt, fallen natürlich die
anderen etwas weg oder werden halt kürzer,
das heißt ich reibe das jetzt hier nur ein.
Muss nicht schrubben, aber ich muss
natürlich auf Zeit gehen,
das heißt ich lasse es einwirken.
Ihr könnt aber auch zum Beispiel den
Faktor Chemie einfach runter schrauben
und sagen: "ich will gar nicht so einen starken
Reiniger zu Hause haben", dann nehmt ihr
zum Beispiel Rasierschaum, könnt hier
den ganzen Backofen mit Rasierschaum
einweichen, auch die Backbleche und das
Backofenrost und dann gebt ihr da
entweder eine Folie drauf, damit es nicht
sofort trocknet und lasst es dann aber
wirklich für 28, ja 24 bis 48
Stunden einwirken.
Das heißt da verringert sich der Faktor
Chemie, aber der Faktor Zeit kommt eben
dazu. Und so könnt ihr eben selbst
abwägen, möchte ich jetzt eine Chemiekeule im
Backofen haben und den reinigen? Oder
will ich etwas schrubben? Also
abschrubben ganz normal mit einer Bürste
geht natürlich auch, aber es geht dann
halt auf die Kraft. Müsst ihr dann wirklich selber
entscheiden. Und hier sieht man schon, das
ist ein ganz starker Reiniger. Das geht
allein schon durch das Einreiben weg, aber
ich werde es jetzt gleich einweichen lassen
und dann geht's mit den Innenschränken
weiter.
[Musik]
Anfangen werde ich jetzt von oben nach
unten, weil natürlich der Schmutz von
oben nach unten fällt.
Ich mache jetzt hier hinten erstmal
unsere Schränke. Das sind offene aber
auch geschlossene Schränke. Ihr seht sie zwar in
den Stories und den Videos immer offen,
aber wir haben sie abends immer zu. Oh das geht jetzt nicht mit dem Handschuh.
wir haben sie abends immer zu, wenn wir schlafen
gehen oder auch tagsüber, wenn wir sie
nicht nutzen.
Das heißt es sind zwar Schränke, die offen
sind, bei Benutzung, und deswegen nicht so
sehr einstauben, aber wenn wir sie eben
nicht brauchen, dann sind sie zu. Trotzdem
muss man die natürlich jetzt ausputzen.
Jetzt mache ich erstmal innen drin und
danach kommen dann eben die Fronten.
Das heißt ich würde jetzt hier aber so vorgehen,
nicht alles ausräumen und eure ganze
Küche vorstellen, sondern wirklich
Schrank für Schrank, Regal für Regal.
Ansonsten entsteht nämlich ein reines
Chaos und wenn ihr dann wirklich mal eine
Pause braucht oder ihr müsst kurzfristig weg, dann sieht die Küche trotzdem wieder ordentlich aus.
Ich habe jetzt hier meinen
Allzweckreiniger, den schüttelt ihr dann
immer vor der Benutzung, hier ein
Handtuch, da kann ich mich schön abstützen
und tu mir nicht weh. Räume alles aus.
Die Sachen werden bei uns auch regelmäßig einfach immer wieder
ausgeräumt, gewaschen.
Und eben auch benutzt.
Und das ist auch der richtige Moment, um Dinge auszumisten, um sie wegzubringen zu verschenken,
oder Sachen weg zu schmeißen.
Denn alles was ihr ein Jahr lang nicht
braucht, also eigentlich gibt es eine Regel:
Wenn ihr etwas drei Monate lang
nicht braucht, braucht es nicht auf Augenhöhe zu sein.
Wenn ihr etwas ein halbes Jahr nicht braucht, muss man sich schon überlegen, "brauche ich es überhaupt?"
Und wenn ihr etwas ein Jahr lang nicht braucht, weil es im Keller liegt oder egal wo
dann verschenkt es oder schmeißt es einfach weg.
Ansonsten belastet euch das nur, euer Haus steht voll
und ihr räumt im Prinzip nur euren Dingen hinterher.
Der Murat hat mal gesagt, alles was du besitzt, besitzt auch dich.
Und da muss ich  immer daran denken
und deswegen steht bei uns halt generell nicht so viel herum,
sondern nur nützliche Dinge.
[Musik]
Jetzt natürlich auch unter der Decke
alles wischen, nicht mischen, sondern wischen.
Und ich habe jetzt hier einen entscheidenden Vorteil, denn
hier waren eigentlich Hochschränke geplant, sowie
in meiner alten Küche mit der Ablage obendrauf
und dann habe ich gesagt, wisst ihr was, ich habe keine Lust mehr auf die Ablage in der Küche, denn
ihr kennt es wahrscheinlich von zu Hause. Die Ablage oben ist immer eine Staub- und Fettablage.
Also haben wir hier alles zugebaut mit
den Hölzern, einfach mit so einer Trockenbauweise.
Und deswegen habe ich
jetzt keine Oberfläche mehr.
Hier muss ich später einfach nur die
Front abwischen und fertig.
Das ist echt ein richtig guter Vorteil davon.
Hier räume ich noch die Kaffeemaschine weg, die ist später dran.
Seht ihr ich hab jetzt hier auch einfach Dinge
ausgemistet, das haben wir mal geschenkt gekriegt.
Benutzen es aber nie, ich tu's jetzt
einfach weg.
Regal eins ist jetzt schon mal fertig, hier unten mache ich erst später, wenn ich die Arbeitsfläche dann mache.
Was ich jetzt hier noch machen werde, sind  Dinge wegräumen, die da nicht hingehören.
Elas Muffins, die sie unbedingt haben wollte. Sie will, dass wir die nachbacken.
Die hat sie gesehen, also habe ich es ihr versprochen. Nach dem Putzen habe ich gesagt.
Das räume ich hier jetzt noch weg.
Mache jetzt hier mit den Regalen oben weiter und dann zeige ich euch gleich wie es weiter geht.
Hier oben bin ich jetzt erst mal fertig. Jetzt werde ich hier seitlich mit meinen Kücheninnenschränken anfangen.
Ich muss euch aber dazu sagen, hier an der Seite habe ich extrem viel Stauraum, aber ich hab noch kein Staugut.
Die meisten Schränke sind noch leer.
Die ganz oben, die brauche ich gar nicht zu machen.
Aber dann geht es gleich mit
dem Kühlschrank weiter und mit den Unterschränken.
Da ist es ziemlich unordentlich.
Das Tuch müsst ihr natürlich
zwischendurch immer mal wieder sauber machen.
Und auch mal das Tuch wechseln.
Also alles was ich hier weniger oft brauche, kommt weiter nach oben
und was ich öfter brauche, kommt hier
weiter nach unten.
Jetzt ist der Kühlschrank dran.
Den werde ich jetzt kurz ausschalten, weil ich ihn jetzt natürlich länger offen halten muss.
Ich räume jetzt einmal kurz aus
Und ich habe übrigens auch ein Kühlschrankvideo schon gemacht. Also wenn ihr wissen wollt, wie man den Kühlschrank richtig einräumt
dann schaut da vorbei. Ich räume jetzt hier
alles aus und habe jetzt hier auch schon
mal Wasser gerichtet. Das ist ganz
frisches Wasser, ein frisches Tuch und
ich gebe es hier ein bisschen Essigessenz rein.
Ihr könnt aber auch wieder Allesreiniger benutzen. Aber den Allesreiniger
nehme ich eigentlich wenn ich den
Kühlschrank wöchentlich auswische
und wenn ich ihn nochmal so grund, so
eine Grundreinigung mache, wasche ich es
gern mit frischem Wasser aus, wo ich das Tuch
einfach immer wieder auch sauber machen kann.
Ingwershots.
Bei starken Verschmutzungen würde ich
euch jetzt raten, alle diese Glasteile
auch noch raus zu nehmen. Hier draußen an
der Tür nehme ich alle raus, aber die hier
die sind echt super sauber. Also da gehe
ich nochmal mit dem Allesreiniger rein.
Mit meinem Essigtuch und dann wird alles
schön gereinigt
Der Kühlschrank ist fertig, die Türen
sind jetzt auch von innen schon geputzt
und jetzt ist das Gefrierfach noch dran,
ja, da sind die Kinder öfter mal dran
Man sieht's! [lacht]
Guckt mal, immer schön Bananen im Vorrat. Und Ingwer im Vorrat. Die Bananen, die
friere ich meist ein, wenn ich merke okay
sie sind schon richtig reif, aber ich brauche
sie gerade nicht, dann friere ich sie einfach so ein. Die werden
zwar von außen braun aber innen sind sie
noch schön weiß und dann könnt ihr
nämlich einfach schälen und für
Smoothies benutzen, habt schön schon mal
die Kälte mit drin
und Ingwer habe ich sowieso immer da.
Also gefroren und frisch. Jetzt ist hier
alles durcheinander und dann nutze ich
jetzt auch die Gelegenheit, um alles wieder
schön aufzuräumen.
Mhh Nussschnecken, will jemand Nussschnecken?
Ich hebe es mal noch auf.
Ich sortier jetzt meine Vorräte hier mal um,
denn ich habe hier in der Küche immer
viele tiefgefrorene Früchte
und nicht so viel Fleisch eigentlich. Also mache ich
jetzt die TK-Früchte hier unten rein.
Ingwer und Bananen lasse ich da oben drin.
Perfekt!
Und das Fleisch kommt dann ins hintere Gefrierfach.
kräuter und gemüse kommen auch hinten ja
Und Kräuter und Gemüse kommen auch hinten rein.
Eine gefrorene Yogurette!
Ihr dürft eure Pause nicht vergessen beim Frühjahrsputz.
Ela kommt, sie hat die Yogurette gerochen!
oh, oh..
Hi Ela!
Ich wollte ich gerade rufen.
Ich habe eine Yogurette gefunden.
Ela: von wo?
Die war.. die lag da so.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, wo ich sie gefunden habe,
dann plündert sie es immer wieder.
Hier habe ich übrigens noch einen zweiten
Kühlschrank mit Gefrierfach,
weil einfach der kleine vorne nicht ausreicht und hier
habe ich dann noch die weiteren Vorräte.
Das habe ich jetzt auch gleichzeitig mit
ausgeräumt.
Der größte Teil ist jetzt schon mal geschafft, jetzt sind die unteren Schränke dran.
Ich fange jetzt hier erst mal hier bei
der Rückwand an.
Danach nehme ich mir hier die Seite vor, bei den Backöfen und am Ende dann die Insel.
Ich fange jetzt einfach auch wieder von oben nach unten an, von links nach rechts.
Die Leisten hier dürft  ihr auch nicht
vergessen, das sind so die Staubflecken.
Die mache ich aber eigentlich auch jeden
Tag sauber, weil da immer was rein krümelt.
Und jetzt einfach alles raus
räumen, auswischen und wieder einräumen.
Ich habe hier übrigens so kleine
Einteiler drin, die sind magnetisch,
Also mit einer magnetischen Rückwand, echt praktisch.
Vor allem kann man hier die Zwischenfächer richtig gut verstellen und so bleibt alles schön ordentlich.
Und dann klippe ich die hier rein und fertig. Kann jetzt wieder alles einräumen.
Hier habe ich so die Kaffeesachen.
Aber da kann ich ja mal ein Organisations-video machen.
Beim Ausräumen achte ich schon darauf,
dass ich die Sachen sortiere.
Denn oftmals kommt hier die Ordnung auch ein
bisschen durcheinander
und wenn ihr es gleich sortiert, habt ihr das
später einfach ein bisschen einfacher.
Müsli, Snacks, kochen, Snacks..
Ich bin halt immer so hin- und hergerissen, sortiere ich es nach Größe oder nach Farben?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was würdet ihr machen? Würdet ihr es nach Größe sortieren?
Also groß zu groß
und dann so die Größe und dann die Größe.
Oder halt eher nach Farben? Weiß? Blau? Gelb?
Stimmt mal ab!
Ich sortiere es jetzt irgendwie ein und dann sortiere ich es wieder um, wenn ihr abgestimmt habt.
So, wie sortiere ichs jetzt ein? Sollen wir  Schnick-Schnack-Schnuck?
Sarah wir machen Schnick-Schnack-Schnuck. Bist du Farbe oder Größe?
Ich bin Größe.
Ich zeige Größe.
Okay.
Drei Durchgänge? Bei drei hat man gewonnen, okay?
Ich bin in sowas schlecht.
Aber nur Schere, Stein, Papier!
Ja! Mehr kann ich auch nicht?!
Okay, Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck!
Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck!
Okay, nochmal.
Okay, du hast wie ich.
Die erste Runde?
ja, erster Punkt.
Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck!
Eins, eins!
Du musst mich kaputt machen!
Ahso!
Nicht nur so...
Ah, ja okay.
Okay, entscheiden: Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck! Schnick, Schnack...
Schnick, Schnack, Schnuck!
Nach Größe!
Also gut.
Bist du jetzt glücklich, ja?
Ja!
So ihr lieben Farben, die Sarah hat euch getrennt.
Ahso halt halt, da gibt es jetzt noch flache und hohe?!
Ja, die sind alle flach.
Schatz, kannst du den Müll schon mal raus bringen?
Murat: ja.
Da kann ich das hier fertig machen.
Ahhh, voll gern!
Die Mülleimer sind übrigens auch immer sauber, denn ich tu sie nach jedem Müll rausbringen,
also jeden Tag einmal kurz durchwischen und da gibt es einen richtig coolen Trick.
Und zwar nehmt jetzt erstmal den Allesreiniger.
Erstmal schön sauber machen.
Kurz auswischen.
Dann nehmt ihr jetzt einfach eine
Küchenrolle oder ihr nehmt das Tuch
welches ihr die ganze Zeit schon benutzt habt und
tut es dann aber in die Wäsche.
Nach dem Mülleimer, finde ich, sollte man das Tuch nicht nochmal weiter benutzen.
Und dann könnt ihr Mülleimergeruch
vorbeugen, indem ihr hier unten jetzt
etwas Küchenrolle reinlegt.
Und nehmt dann etwas Orangen- oder Teebaumöl.
Ich mag ganz gerne Orange und tropft es hier einfach auf das Tuch.
[Macht Scratch-Geräusche]
Yo, Yo!
Kürchenparty geht weiter!
Die Unterschränke sind jetzt auch fertig. Die Sally ist glücklich.
Denn die Innenschränke sind jetzt alle ausgewaschen.
Jetzt geht es an die Oberflächen. Hier bin
ich jetzt erstmal an der Kochstelle.
Ich habe übrigens den Topf immer hier stehen. Zum einen ist er dekorativ und passt in die Küche.
Petrol und Senf. Und zum
anderen benutze ich ihn einfach echt oft
und er passt einfach nicht hier in den
Unterschrank, weil ich da andere Töpfe drin habe.
Und ich finde ihn  halt schön. So, die Teekanne kann ich jetzt auch mal zum Auswaschen nach hinten stellen.
Bei der Kochstelle mache ich es jetzt so.
Das muss ich auch mehrmals machen in der Woche.
Das sind einfach Dinge.. Frühjahrsputz bedeutet nicht, dass ich nur Dinge mache, die ich nur im Frühjahr mache
Sondern einfach Dinge, die ich noch zusätzlich mache.
Hier erstmal vom Dampfabzug, die Filter auswechseln bzw. in die Spülmaschine.
Ich habe jetzt auch die Spülmaschine
noch nicht so voll.
Das heißt hier kann ich jetzt alles reingeben und auch gleich anschalten
und wenn ich dann nämlich fertig bin, ist die Spülmaschine auch fertig,
und die kann ich dann auch noch zum Schluss reinigen.
Die Edelstahlteile, die Abdeckung wasche ich per Hand.
Und die Filter kommen in die Spülmaschine, gemeinsam mit diesen zweite Ebenen Teilen vom Waschbecken.
Und ich hole auch gleich noch alles aus der Kaffeemaschine raus
dann kann ich nämlich die Spülmaschine anschmeißen, auf einem Kurzprogramm muss jetzt nicht so
mega heiß werden, ich habe sie nämlich nicht voll.
und kann dann die Küche weiter putzen und später mich noch um die Spülmaschine kümmern.
Hier muss ich es nur ausbürsten und das per Hand reinigen.
Und da müsst ihr jetzt einfach auf euren Geräten schauen, das darf zum Beispiel nicht in die Spülmaschine
weil es dann wahrscheinlich auch ganz blind wird und sich verzieht.
Das reinige ich jetzt kurz alles per Hand und der Rest kann jetzt schon mal angemacht werden.
Oh Murat, wie passend! Kannst du kurz abtrocknen?
Murat: ja, ich komme.
Josch: Verzieh dich so lange du kannst. [lacht]
[beide lachen]
Murat: nein, natürlich nicht.
Wenn ihr übrigens kalkige Geräte habt oder Wasserkocher,
wir haben hier jetzt die Teekanne, dann gebt ihr jetzt einfach Wasser rein und Zitronensäure.
Wir haben zwar eine BWT-Anlage, also eine Entkalkungsanlage,
aber trotzdem hat man ja natürlich mit der Zeit Kalk drin.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier einfach Wasser rein
und dann wirklich nur ganz wenig Zitronensäure
Das kann ich es aufkochen lassen und das heiße Wasser benutze ich dann aber auch gleich noch
um das Waschbecken sauber zu machen.
Das mache ich auch regelmäßig, aber ich
empfehle euch wirklich
eine Enthärtungsanlage, denn ihr schont eure Geräte, ihr schon eure Rohre, ihr schont eure Spülmaschine.
Beim Duschen braucht ihr weniger Duschgel, weniger Shampoo also, es lohnt sich wirklich.
Auf den ersten Blick
denkt man sich vielleicht: "oh, wieso brauche ich das?"
Aber glaubt mir es lohnt sich.
Ja.
Man schont wirklich alles und es bleibt ziemlich kalkfrei.
Und das Wasser schmeckt besser und weicher.
Und dieses Zitronensäurewasser ist jetzt wirklich der beste Kalklöser.
Das nehmt ihr jetzt, geht zum Waschbecken und könnt es einfach schön über das Waschbecken gießen.
Der Kalk löst sich fast von alleine.
Und damit könnt ihr auch den Herd noch ein
bisschen putzen, also überall, wo Kalk ist.
Ins Badezimmer könnt ihr es mitnehmen.
Einfach drüber gießen.
Mit meinem Allzweckreiniger reinige ich
jetzt hier noch im Filter drinnen.
Denn der ist ja auch fettlösend.
Und jetzt komme ich zum Ceranfeld.
Da habe ich einen ganz normalen Ceranfeld-Reiniger,
den ich jeden Tag benutze.
Der ist nämlich für Edelstahl und für Ceranfelder.
Und da nehme ich die weiche Seite des Schwammes.
Und kann jetzt hier schön drüber putzen.
Und danach schön auswischen und trocken reiben.
Sieht aus wie neu!
Tadaa!
Was gibt's jetzt noch zu tun?
Jetzt werde ich die Fronten putzen. Dafür nehme ich einfach jetzt ein frisches Tuch,
meinen Allzweckreiniger, mache hier die Schränke erst mal von außen sauber.
Alle Fronten von vorne und dann bleiben im Prinzip nur noch die Backöfen und das Waschbecken.
Jetzt sind auch alle Fronten und
Oberflächen sauber.
Ich fühle mich wirklich super gut. Jetzt kommen noch die Waschbecken dran, ich mache jetzt hier das erste.
Dann mach ich die Backöfen gleich
noch fertig und das zweite Waschbecken.
Ich mache immer eins dann eben ganz zum Schluss.
Hier nehmt ihr jetzt, je nach Verschmutzungsgrad, auch einen Waschbeckenreiniger.
Ich hab da einfach so einen Edelsteinreiniger, den ich auch immer benutze.
Deswegen habe ich auch hier kaum Verfärbungen.
Wenn ihr aber wirklich auch mal starke Verfärbungen habt
ihr könnt auch immer gut Cola nehmen.
Die hatte ich beim Ausräumen im Getränkekühlschrank gefunden.
Und damit könnt ihr die Toilette gut sauber machen, hier das Waschbecken sauber machen.
Und ich werde jetzt aber gleich noch alles, einfach damit es wirklich rein und sauber wird,
mit einem Dampfreiniger durchpusten. So werden auch die Rohre unten sauber.
Hier diese kleinen Ecken, wo ich nicht so gut dran komme, werden sauber.
Und ich kann eben auch alles schön bakterienfrei bekommen.
Mit dem heißen Wasser, mit dem heißen Dampf.
Wenn ihr ganz starke Verkalkungen habt, könnt ihr auch hier wieder Zitronensäure und warmes Wasser nehmen.
Oder auch ein bisschen Essig.
Bei Essig muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil Essig Kunststoff angreift.
Also gerade bei Armaturen, bei Duschhauben zum Beispiel, lieber eher Zitronensäure nehmen.
Da macht ihr nämlich nichts kaputt, also auch keine Dichtungen usw.
So, jetzt kurz ausspülen.
Jetzt wird alles schön mit Dampf sauber
gemacht.
Und bei Dampf hat man auch den Vorteil, dass man nicht so einen großen Wasserverbrauch hat
wie wenn man jetzt ständig mit fließendem Wasser arbeitet.
Und gerade der Abfluss oder diese kleinen Stellen hier im Waschbecken sind ebenso kleine Details,
die man gerne im Alltag oft vergisst, die man auch nicht sieht aber man riecht sie, wenn man es eben nicht sauber macht.
Und hier könnt ihr entweder, wie gesagt, mit einem Dampfreiniger rein
mit heißem Wasser oder ihr könnt auch mal Natron reingeben.
Natron reinigt nämlich auch und neutralisiert vor allem
Gerüche.
Genug eingewirkt.
Guckt wie neu und Wasser sparen könnt ihr hier übrigens, wenn ihr das Blech nicht per Hand reinigt,
sondern einfach mit in den Geschirrspüler gebt.
Bei mir ist er jetzt aber schon an und da habe ich es kurz per Hand gereinigt
aber dann könnt ihr euch da den Arbeitsvorgang sparen.
Jetzt muss ich nur noch kurz den Backofen auswischen und trocknen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier zwei dreimal, damit
wirklich der ganze Reiniger entfernt wird.
Wie neu!
Ich habe jetzt nur noch drei Stationen.
Nummer eins: die Fenster. Nummer zwei: das Waschbecken. Nummer drei: der Boden.
Die Fenster putze ich jetzt erst mal innen, alle Rahmen und dann von außen.
Nur bei außen- lass ich vielleicht Murat machen.
Ja, der soll mir noch mithelfen.
[Musik]
Und abziehen!
Das schönste haben ich mir bis zum Schluss aufgespart.
Da sieht man gleich Ergebnisse.
[Musik]
Während Murat jetzt draußen noch unten das Fenster macht kann, kann ich schon das Waschbecken machen.
Du kannst auch dann damit das Brett
machen, weißt du?
Aber ganz zum Schluss und dann tu ich das Tuch eh in die Wäsche.
Murat: Danke!
Sally: Ne, hier noch eins.
Murat: Ah, auch noch?
Sally: Hallo? Um die Ecke?
Murat: Ahso.
Sally: ja so einmal. Musst gar nicht drücken.
Sally: Cool, ge! Und das Fenster war schon sehr sehr
dreckig.
Murat: Krass!
Sally: Bombe, oder?
Murat: Ah, der saugt das auch auf?
Sally: Haja unten ist doch der Behälter.
Sally: Fenstersauger Murat.
Ich habe es geschafft, die Küche ist
sauber!
Murat darf jetzt noch saugen und wischen, wobei ich gestern schon gesaugt und gewischt hab.
Beim kompletten Frühjahrsputz, aber jetzt habe ich hier
natürlich auch nochmal Dreck verursacht.
Das darf er jetzt machen und morgen gehe ich dann in die Badezimmer und mach die Badezimmer noch sauber.
Also man nimmt sich am besten immer jeden Tag ein bisschen was vor, denn wenn man
es richtig gründlich machen, will jeden
Schrank rein haben will und dann gleich
noch ausmistet und aussortiert und wieder einsortiert, dann ist es doch für einen Tag ziemlich viel.
Also teil es euch gut auf, hört gute Musik dabei, trinkt und esst zwischendurch.
Und habt viel Spaß beim Putzen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüssi!
Jetzt bin ich glücklich, denn die Küche
ist wieder sauber!